i said that to logan i don't know if you
uh seen the video where i was about to
bring it so how did that happen so you
come out logan logan did that video
what logan did the video what was the
issue with the video that you had uh so
there was the japan video which i know a
lot of people hate it but so long story
short i found someone dead like that
before in japan uh not in japan it
wasn't exactly the same
but um
so when i seen the video it was like six
am obviously he they'd released it
us time and i'm waking up in the uk like
just check on what's on twitter and then
obviously it happened i didn't know who
logan was didn't have a clue
uh which was verified because there was
a podcast beforehand where i was like
never heard of this guy i don't know who
he was talking about when other people
were mentioning him right and yeah i
just was like
it just triggered me in in the biggest
way you know because he he was just a
young immature kid who was making light
of the situation that i was like you
really don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about here yeah and clearly he
missed the mark obviously the whole
world knows that and uh when i'm talking
about him and i'm talking about what
he's doing and all that towards the end
i started
talking about all the kids who message
me who've had mental health issues and
before i know it like i'm [ __ ] crying
like i'm actually like yeah
like it's all [ __ ] happening there
you know what i mean and then in the end
i was like
[ __ ] me i just because i'd actually
edited out bits where i was like i want
to [ __ ] punch the [ __ ] out with you
you little prick you know like because i
thought it's not really going to play in
my favor from threatening violence yeah
yeah yeah um
and then i uploaded it and that was the
video
that i think put me on to another level
uh i got 200 000 subscribers in 24 hours
in one day [ __ ] me yeah so
that was when i was like wow this uh so
it's probably a lot of people shared
that frustration and you were able to
articulate in a way and it's like yo
this guy is in a genuine way yeah i
think that's where i've nailed certain
things before where people feel what i'm
feeling but i can just say it in a way
that just rounds it up nicely i we've uh
when we were doing those those videos
during the pandemic we did these like
turn your phone videos i don't know if
you ever saw those right and i think we
were kind of doing a very similar thing
it's like people felt a certain way
about what was happening culturally or
politically and we were able to like
slice it thin and articulate it to the
point where they felt safe sharing
because sometimes it's scary to say an
opinion especially in
that's what you do fantastically well
now you nail it but it's also it's a
responsibility that we now have when we
have these platforms to kind of say what
other people want to say but can't quite
nail it in there with a gift that you
have and the gift that you guys have
like it's hard um
but i didn't really do it for that
reason yeah at the time i was like i'm
just [ __ ] raging right now yeah yeah
yeah i think it would be a funny prank
though if there was someone who did want
to kill themselves to like just do it in
the back of one of logan's videos bro
[Music]
do it and i think you should talk to
somebody if you know you feel like apps
100 percent yeah here's the hotline that
you call right now right now on the
video call right here but
if you still after calling we're like no
this is the right decision i'm committed
exactly find where they're doing
impulsive
i mean in america
at some point you know what i mean you
guys have shootings regularly is that
crazy to you guys yeah we think you guys
are all [ __ ] crazy no no it's
normally schools that's a dumb question
you don't know like is
you've never been in class and you're
just like [ __ ] everyone like you never
had that this is the thing i'm really
glad that we didn't have guns when i was
in class because it would have been the
one of the guys who was looking it up
but yeah all right
you like you got suspended something for
like pissing on the window of like the
teacher's lounge you did your research
yeah yeah uh yeah
i was like 10 years old and i ran up to
my teachers lounge and i was like
pissing on the window and flipping them
and then imagine you had an ak brother
yeah exactly yeah exactly
i had major problems back then a lot of
testosterone yeah yeah yeah a lot of
spots on my face and that yeah
it wasn't good but then you see these
young youtube guys i don't know if
you've seen any of these guys before
they flip yeah and they're like i don't
know why women don't want to have sex
with me i'm charismatic you've seen
these guys these insults yeah yeah they
are terrifying yeah go to scotland there
you go
yeah yeah yeah don't need to get a gun
out just go to scotland yeah yeah so
what do we do with these installs if
they're like on the on youtube being
like yeah why does no one like me like
what's the remedy for that
they they genuinely freaked me the [ __ ]
out though like they are all the same
they they make so many warning videos
i'm like why wasn't just send it to the
cops like
it's so [ __ ] weird like i'm gonna
show you all i'm gonna show you next
week when i kill everybody oh really
you'll respect me oh
that's what they say when i say
something you have a good american
accent and i just realized when you were
imitating an incel
that you have a really good american
accent
you could play an incel there you go
there's no way this wouldn't be
believable
one hell of a model yeah can we talk
about more of his beefs yes yes yes so
you had logan logan and then you guys
right you guys reconciled uh logan
reached out uh well yeah yeah because i
made that i made another video where
basically he
he came after me after i was the one who
basically reminded ksi
you got to call someone out remember
like
because i was basically the guy who
prompted ksi i was interviewing him
after his fight and i went don't forget
you're supposed to call out logan paul
oh because he mentioned it beforehand to
me being like don't let me forget this
because he was all hyped you know
and that and then logan remembered that
i'd made the original video on him and
he was like let me get him back for that
you know call me the white dj colors
and then i did my other video back to
him because i was like i just called up
the boys and i was like right we got the
million subscriber it happened
because i knew i was going to do a fire
video back to him and then he he rang me
up he was like that was pretty good fair
play
and he was so cool about that he
appreciates content no yeah he knows
what he he's doing so then i was like
when you come to the uk
we'll get you on the podcast but he did
a video with casey neistat where casey
had went in on him right afterwards
and he didn't really give him a chance
to talk and casey just annihilated him
on that video and i was like okay
i'll give you an actual chance here and
then that was when uh i think you
respected that you know what i mean so
that went well
uh beef wise i don't know who else has
there been wait but how much did logan
pay you for you to say that he won three
rounds against mayweather
do you like that yeah how much did he
pay well it depends on what you're
classing as winning rounds i i class it
as punching your opponent what are you
classing at no but you actually have to
like connect
he can throw a lot of points but if
they're not hitting anything mayweather
did his thing where you know he didn't
he didn't do a great deal because he was
waiting for logan to do what conor
mcgregor did which is tire out and then
he started walking him down and
mayweather just couldn't hurt him
that was a problem it's not about
hurting it's about to connect more like
mayweather had more shots that he
actually bothered about it
i feel like
do you think he won three rounds i 100
think he won three rounds i also think
conor won three rounds i think uh
mayweather as he's gotten older he's
just slowing the [ __ ] down and even yeah
and
the point is is what we were told
beforehand was mayweather do whatever he
wants to whatever he'll win whenever he
wants he'll put him down whenever he
wants that was not the truth though you
even got a footage of him in the corner
where his corner going to floyd you got
him with a job
he's [ __ ] hard at him with the jumper
he's six for [ __ ] two yeah i'm a
[ __ ] yeah you know what i mean so i
just think look but whatever happened in
that fight like logan showed
how good he is in terms of the kid who
just picked the boxing dude it's
unbelievable that he lasted that long i
don't think people really get it and i
think it was the cardio absolutely it's
like if the cardio holds up he still has
the size and he hits hard enough where
where floyd had to respect it but he
just didn't get tired i told him before
that i said logan whatever you do first
round do not empty the clip yeah do not
do that what are you doing watching the
first round
[Laughter]
[Music]
baits you into that he's such a clever
little bastard isn't it you know but
look i think for those who don't know
what it's like to be in a ring with an
old head who can manage his energy and
walk you down in like old man you yeah
it was it must have been hard for logan
to do that and i think that he's the
only guy out of all the youtube boxers
who probably could have
i don't know maybe jake but jake's a
different kind of
fighter yeah he would have gone for the
knockout and that would have ended up
either
good or very very bad yeah i think
there's another thing that like
i believe that logan
convinced himself that he was going to
win
and you need to do that in order to
train that hard that being said
i think that he also accepted that a win
was survival absolutely and i think
after a couple rounds of being hit by
mayweather but not being hurt
and not being dominated and feeling good
on cardio
where most people in a normal regular
fight would be like [ __ ] i'm losing how
am i going to change this i think the
fact that he wasn't being so dominated
he actually got excited yeah he was
losing rounds maybe or maybe he was
getting tagged but the fact that he
wasn't like hurt
i think the key is in the last round or
two you could say floyd turned it down a
notch he was like i ain't going to get
i'm not going to feel yeah i'm not going
to do it yeah and uh the last thing i
want to do is get tired and end up
getting my head hurt you know i mean so
um i look at logan i think the only
problem with him in in the ring is his
state of mind i don't think he's a
killer like he has all the talent but
jake is a dude
jake is dark yeah you know what i mean
he wants to hurt you and he also knows
he could turn you out yeah the lights go
off that's why i can turn you over i'm
convinced that's why like i don't think
it's necessarily
like
like johnny wilder you look at him you
think you really should not be able to
hurt that guy the way you do but he's he
wants to kill you yeah he's even said
that yeah so i think that when you have
that darkness it helps